à dix jours des jeux olympiques de
sotchi nous vous proposons tout au long
de la semaine de découvrir une autre
facette de la russie une russie loin des
grands centres et loin des sentiers
battus notre correspondant jean françois
bélanger est monté à bord du
transsibérien pour traverser le plus
grand pays du monde et nous offrir une
série de reportages inédits
nous débutons ce soir par une visite de
ce train mythique qui fait rêver
beaucoup de monde
13h30 le gard jaroslav ce qui est moche
ou
la numéro deux à destination du gladio
stocks
le transsibérien s'apprête à partir pour
un voyage d'une semaine jusqu'à l'autre
bout du pays
l'occasion pour nous de découvrir une
autre rue si méconnu une russie loin des
sentiers battus
nancy derrien est un train de légende un
train à nulle autre pareille
le plus long chemin de fer au monde près
de 2300 km à travers l'oural et la
sibérie
il fait la fierté de toute la russie
pour angelica pas d'obinna travailler à
bord du transsibérien est un honneur
presque un privilège et instaurer fait
partie de notre histoire je suis une
patriote que j'aime mon pays et je suis
très fier et travailler à bord de ce
train voulue par le dard alexandre iii
est terminée au début du siècle dernier
au prix de terribles sacrifices humains
et financiers
le transsibérien a permis d'affirmer la
mainmise de la russie sur la sibérie est
sûre c'est formidable richesse devenant
ainsi la colonne vertébrale de la russie
moderne
le transsibérien facile de par sa
démesure
il fait rêver mais attire bien des
étrangers comme nathalie et d'une smart
qui viennent tout juste de se marier
mordus du train il vient de s'offrir un
voyage de noces bien singulier c'est
quelque chose qu'on a toujours voulu
faire et ça a pris de l'importance au
fur et à mesure qu'on s'est mise en en
parler c'est un mode de transport qu'on
aime vraiment c'est le plaisir du voyage
terrestre
elle est britannique nuit australienne
ensemble ils font le voyage de londres à
sydney entre un bain 1000 km 14 pays
traversés en quatre mois et demi elle ce
week end c'est le voyage qui planta les
destinations peuvent être génial
amérique le train c'est le voyage mais
pour angelica pas domina le chemin de
fer n'est pas synonyme de vacances
pour elle le train est un mode de vie un
syndicat et une pagode liszt à une
responsable de wagons chargés du
bien-être des passagers de la propreté à
bord de la sécurité
angelica vit et travaille à bord du
train quinze jours d'affilée sans
s'arrêter
le sqbb étiez une vocation
on finit par s'y habituer aux mêmes de
vie parallèle une vie à la maison et une
vie à bord du train j'adore mon métier
j'aime communiquer avec les gens ça
m'apporte beaucoup de satisfaction et
du matin jusqu'au soir angelica doit
nettoyer accueillir les passagers leur
donner draps et oreillers et surtout
s'assurer qu'il ya toujours de l'eau
chaude pour le thé plus qu'une simple
boisson ici un véritable du brillant
sociale c'est une tradition russe de
boire du thé au long du voyage
le thé est une boisson qui rapproche les
gens russie qui les lie au même titre
que la vodka nice vivent les work
boris qui atterrit golfe
amoureux du train qu'il prend chaque
fois possible c'est à dire chaque fois
qu'il en ait un car en russie
la plupart des traits ne sont pas très
rapide c'est d'ailleurs selon boris leur
principal est à la base prize
je n'aime pas lisse et rapide pour moi
le train est l'endroit parfait pour
s'arrêter y réfléchir et faire le point
sur sa vie faire des plans pour l'avenir
fête à bord du transsibérien le temps
apparaît comme suspendu
beau traverser sept fuseaux horaires
leurs abords et toujours celle de moscou
pour passer le temps natori et dean ont
apporté des jeux de la lecture
ils ont aussi entrepris de rédiger un
blog sur leur aventure
sur leur encontre sur la vie à bord du
train le confort à bord est une notion
toute relative par exemple il n'ya pas
de douche dans le train même en première
classe pour son avis les voyageurs ne
peuvent compter que sur des robinets
comme celui ci
et pour ceux qui sa demande il n'y a pas
d'eau chaude
le transsibérien fait quelques douzaine
d'escales en route et chaque arrêt est
l'occasion pour les voyageurs de se
dégourdir les jambes
et de faire le plein de provisions le
voyage est fantastique on a beaucoup de
plaisir à gens entrent et sortent de
notre cabine
on fait plein de rencontres avec les
gens du coin c'est une occasion génial
de voir des gens qu'on ne croiserai
jamais autrement mieux comme quoi
les rencontres en partie intégrante
voyage en train meilleur moyen de passer
le temps que l'on soit dans un
compartiment de 1re ou 2e classe ou
encore dans le wagon de queue l'appeler
ici la bagarre dans une troisième place
à aire ouverte que vous choisissez
exprès pour ce faire de nouvelles
connaissances
j'aime communiquer avec les gens j'aime
raconter des histoires écouter celle des
autres ça chauffe ça fait passer le
temps
le voyage passe plus vite a indiqué
openskies nord le wagon plate carte
c'est une aire ouverte on voit tout le
monde
on entend tout ce qui se dit donc il est
toujours possible de s'approcher et de
se joindre à une conversation en cours
c'est toujours une bonne occasion de
rencontrer des gens
wagon restaurant et de notre endroit
privilégié pour les échanges espaces
communs accessibles à tous
c'est un carrefour où les langues se
délient date yen à bâle andina la
responsable du restaurant devient un peu
une confidente par la force des choses
la preuve les gens nous confient des
choses qu'il ne dirait jamais à qui que
ce soit d'autre parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils ne vont pas nous revoir les
hommes se plaignent de leurs femmes ont
fini par tout savoir se re on doit être
un peu psychologue pour personne la main
pour nathalie et jean le séjour à bord
du transsibérien tire à sa fin
prochaine étape pour eux la mongolie la
chine d'autres pays d'autres trains
d'autres défis
les bourdes à tiana et angelica bad
terminus la vie à bord du transsibérien
est un éternel recommencement
et d
hahaha
arrivée des passagers qui vont et qui
viennent
à bord de ce train
l'autre pareil en
2 les gens
demain notre périple en thrace poursuit
et nous emmène dans un endroit hyper
secret théâtre du pire accident
nucléaire de l'histoire de la russie
gardé secret pendant 30 ans et qui fait
encore des victimes de nos jours